Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks for submitting
questions for the Q&A today.
I know a lot of you in international countries
are asking about Netflix episodes.
Since it’s different in every country you’ll
have to check with whatever streaming service
you use.
Netflix is different in every country and
it’s a giant headache, but everyone should
be able to find a way to watch everything.
And thank you for all your bonus suggestions.
I think next week will be a Michonne slice
and dice video.
In case you just found me and you have no
idea what’s going on, I’m doing a lot
of walking dead this fall.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll have a link to my video schedule in
the description.
So just a general spoiler warning for everything
through season 4 as we start doing questions.
All the season 5 questions are speculation,
so I don’t really consider them spoilery.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
Here we go
1- nicnacz.
Was Seth Gilliam’s Character already introduced?
Who is he and what’s his connection to Rick’s
Group?
Yes, they introduced him officially at Comic
Con as Father Gabriel from the comics.
He’s playing a comic book character but
that doesn’t mean he’ll be exactly like
father gabriel in the comics.
You guys know the drill with that.
Of all the brand new characters, he’s one
of the two I’m most excited to see.
I love Seth Gilliam and based on the types
of characters he’s been playing more recently,
like on Teen Wolf.
I’m interested to see how he handles spirituality
inside the Walking Dead Universe.
His Teen Wolf character is also this soft
spoken mystical healer, so of course they’d
cast him as a religious figure.
Even if he weren’t a man of god, he would
still probably have come off as the spiritual
one.
The other big character I’m really interested
in right now is this crazy looking policewoman
smacking Beth around.
Right now I’m thinking of her as Lady Negan,
but that’s not who she is.
They didn’t genderbend that character from
the comics.
2 - Cameren Ceniceros.
How do you think they’ll give significant
screen time to each character this season.
There was one point in the trailer when there
was over a dozen on screen at the same time.
The short answer is they won’t.
They’ll just pick three or four characters
that will get solo type episodes like in season
4.
And the rest of the characters will just get
moments during the group scenes.
And when I say solo episodes.
I don’t mean they’ll go off on their own.
I just mean the majority of the scenes in
certain episodes will focus on the biggest
handful of characters.
Beth is the one exception this year.
She’ll get a lot more screentime in that
messed up looking hospital place.
We don’t know where that is yet.
But it seems like she’ll be there for the
entire first half of the season.
3 - Neto De Toro.
I’ll never understand why it’s okay to
have zombies with exploding heads but they
can’t drop f-bombs?
This is a weird standards and practices thing,
at least in the United States.
Each country deals with censorship in a slightly
different way.
Standards and Practices are people that work
inside the networks and try to avoid shows
getting fined by the FCC.
So if they think the FCC will complain about
the use of a word, or a certain level of voilence
or sex.
They’ll ask the showrunner, in this case,
scott gimple.
To remove or edit something out.
There is no logic to it.
What passes for okay changes every year, sometimes
it gets even more strict in later seasons
for no apparent reason.
The DVD is the exception.
AMC can slap a warning label on it to avoid
potential fines and they can leave everything
in.
It’s the same deal with the way movies get
rated in the United States.
4 - Gab Borja.
Do you think *spoiler’s Hand will be cut
off in season 5?
I just omitted the name because most people
should already know who this is you’re asking
about.
I do not think his hand will be chopped off,
although they have joked about it at conventions.
There is a major character in the comics that
loses a hand, but the show hasn’t done it
yet.
Recently Norman Reedus tweeted a picture of
a chopped off hand with a ring on it.
What I think really happened was they cut
off a random person’s hand as a way to wink
at the comic book fans.
I don’t think that person was the big character
everyone thinks it is.
He’ll probably be fine.
Why not you ask?
Mostly for sake of practicality.
It’s expensive and extremely time consuming
to apply prosthetics for a missing hand, along
with creating the digital effects to support
it.
So it makes filming with that character way
more expensive over time.
And even though Walking Dead makes a crap
ton of money, it’s the most profitable show
on cable right now next to Big Bang Theory.
It’s also one of the most expensive shows.
AMC spends more making walking dead than HBO
spends
making Game of Thrones.
5 - Darcy Peterson.
During the governor’s attack on the prison.
Do you think he would have really let the
survivors leave the prison unharmed if they
chose to give it up?
I don’t think he knew what he was going
to do till it all started going down.
I think he’d really only thought through
it up to the point of the megaphone and the
threats.
And then something inside him just snapped
while Rick was trying to reason with him.
Had the survivors chosen to go he would have
eventually found a reason to go after them.
I also think the prison would have turned
into another Woodbury.
So either way, the governor would have ended
up going crazy again and killing a bunch of
people.
6 - jgcujo.
Everyone has been talking about Daryl’s
character maybe being gay, do you think he
is?
Is there something going on between him and
carol?
I saw this, I’m not sure why people thought
he might be gay.
It is okay for a man to not try to have sex
with every woman that passes his field of
vision.
Maybe it was because of his lack of sexual
relationships since the apocalypse started.
Daryl never really struck me as a ladies man,
but I don’t think he’s gay.
I think he’s got an undiagnosed personality
disorder that causes him to recoil a little
from the thought of intimacy.
Just to clarify, I don’t think he’s asexual.
That’s like the absence of sexual feelings
under normal circumstances.
For the last 4 years or so, Daryl has been
living in a wasteland of death, so no one
is thinking normally.
He’s just now starting to think of the survivors
as his real family.
So I think what we’ll see is him opening
up to people.
If that continues, the natural progression
would be for him to develop a more intimate
relationship if the opportunity presented
itself.
I know there’s some Carol/Daryl shipping,
but I think neither one of them is looking
for that kind of a relationship right now.
What we might see in a future season is a
guest character come on and Daryl get close
with her.
But Scott Gimple has said that at no time
in season 5 will they address Daryl’s sexuality.
It’s just not something they think is interesting.
From a storytelling perspective.
7- Ciaran McFadden.
Do you think they’ll kill off a main character
like Daryl or Glenn?
Neither one of them is completely untouchable,
but I don’t see them getting rid of Daryl
he’s one of their most popular characters.
The next main character to die will probably
be one of the smaller ones.
There have been a lot of Glenn Rumors, I don’t
know if there’s any truth there.
But I’ve heard everything from Maggie Pregnancy
to Baseball bats.
I wouldn’t be surprised if Bob died though,
it feels like they’d give him a big hero
moment to prove to himself he wasn’t terrible.
And then right away a bunch of walkers would
swarm him.
So he could die a hero.
Instead of just being an alcoholic.
8 - Frazer Chard.
Is there any truth to the statement that Robert
Kirkman wants the show to run for 12 seasons?
Every Time I’ve heard Kirkman talk about
the series, first he’s said he’ll keep
writing the comics till no one buys them anymore,
which is basically forever.
And It’s almost the same situation for the
tv series.
Because tv is so much harder to produce than
a comic, eventually the show will become to
expensive to produce.
That’s what the spin off is for.
A way to continue the show, without having
to pay crazy extra money for season 20.
Actors salaries at that point would be in
the millions of dollars.
9 - braders.
Are you sponsored by Razer now?
I’ve been seeing that razer headset a lot.
That’s funny, no.
I just wanted some more color in my background.
I have these grey sound panels on the wall
and it looks kind of dull.
I wish I had a sponsorship.
Right now no one is paying me to do anything.
So anytime you see something in a video or
I mention something it’s just because that’s
what I’m thinking about at that moment.
I will say, product related stuff might be
happening in the next year.
But I don’t know when.
If there’s ever something I think you guys
will really enjoy and the opportunity comes
up then I’d do something like that.
But generally I don’t expect anything like
that to happen anytime soon.
Whenever brands go after creators it’s usually
fashion and cosmetics companies.
Even Pewdie Pie doesn’t do a lot of straight
up ads.
He does integrations with like Humble Bundle
and other services like that.
Like giving out discount codes.
That’s a little less invasive.
Ad stuff is like a whole different part of
being a youtuber that I’m starting to learn
about.
Most of my experience working on the platform
is just making content.
The business side of it is a whole different
group of people.
So I try not to worry about that stuff.
10 - drake henderson-dumont.
How do you think the tv show will end?
Will Rick ever die?
I think they’ll end it in some ambiguous
way where one or a couple of the characters
just keep traveling around trying to survive.
They’ll leave it in a way that lets you
know that things in general will just continue.
I do think by the end several of the characters
will be dead, it’s a really big cast.
It would be disingenuous if everyone got to
live for 12 seasons.
I’d like to see Beth and maybe Carl amongst
the last people standing.
That would be one of the less depressing endings.
If you wanted it to be super hardcore you’d
kill everyone else and let Rick survive.
I don’t think Rick wants to live if it means
everyone he cares about is dead.
That’s kind of what happened to the governor.
So just a quick reminder, Walking Dead bonus
videos on sundays now.
Next week is Michonne.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And feel free to make requests in the comments.
I will be live-tweeting the episodes when
they get here.
So links for all my social in the description.
I’m generally okay with not being spoilery,
pretty good.
Congratulations to this week’s giveaway
winner, Alex Dredge, you win an amazon giftcard.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Next round of the giveaway starts next week
when I post that Michonne video.
Right now click here to learn more about the
new characters in season 5 and click here
for my top 5 rick grimes moments.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!